have you seen the most popular seed from
the Harry and Megan documentary
how do you explain that you bow to your
grandmother
and that you will need to curtsy
especially to an American like that's
weird now I'm starting to realize this
is a big deal I mean Americans will
understand this we have Medieval Times
dinner and tournament it was like that
like I curtsied as though I was like
[Music]
laughs
pleasure to meet you your majesty
like was that okay
it was so intense
I was so stupid oh yeah I had to bow
down to my husband's dumb Grandma you
know her just dumb stupid Grandma one of
the most dignified and beloved people on
Earth yeah wasn't that wasn't that right
hubby what a dumb thing we did huh he's
just sitting there like you'd see
just oh man my life why did I do this
I'm so uh I could have had a good future
but then
it's so disrespectful
what Megan Markle is doing here
it's disrespectful obviously to the
light Queen it's disrespectful to her
husband it's disrespectful to the people
of the United Kingdom because she is
insulting their Sovereign and their
entire political order
and why is she doing that I don't even
think she's doing it intentionally I
don't think she's setting out to insult
the people of the UK she's doing it
because she doesn't believe that
anything matters other than
her individualism
her individual expression why do I have
to engage in this formal behavior that
is prescribed by tradition in the word I
just come on this is so dumb and stupid
I just want to do whatever I want to do
we fall into that error too
we fall into that error a little bit too
in America the left and the right the
left obviously all they care about is
people doing whatever they want at least
when it comes to sex when it comes to
drugs when it comes to the social issues
but the right to the right says
individuals should be able to do
whatever the hell they want
some people on the right think that
that's true of sex and drugs but
especially when it comes to the economy
well you know
if Larry Fink over there a Black Rock
wants to
force all of the companies under his
under his control to pursue the radical
left-wing ESG agenda well that's his
right build your own BlackRock
if he wants to completely upend our
political order and if a handful of
people forget about just the asset
managers Silicon Valley if Facebook and
Twitter and Google want to completely
rewrite how the Public Square works in
the United States or self-governing
Republic
well that just build your own
Communications
build your own Public Square build your
own
handful of companies that control 90 of
the flow of information around our
country
no how about how about I just wield the
government that I have maybe a little
bit of control in
to stop you from doing that
maybe we recognize as Edmund Burke
recognized that there is a higher form
of freedom than individual freedom when
Edmund Burke writes in the most famous
passage in Reflections on the revolution
in France
that
there is such a thing as the spirit of
an exalted Freedom that keeps alive even
in that remains alive even in servitude
itself
and this is one of the Great
Revelations of Christianity
is that
there is a a higher form of freedom than
just pursuing your appetites whenever
you want that you can actually be the
freest man in the world even when you're
being tortured even when you're even
when you're in undergoing conversion
therapy that doesn't really exist even
even when you are in servitude even when
you are in prison
there's a higher form of freedom
in the cultivation of one's rational
will and the suppression of one's basest
instincts and the pursuit of something
higher and good and true and and we can
express that exalted freedom in another
way not just through our spiritual lives
but in political life
that to have a good flourishing Society
is a a much higher sort of freedom
even if it means in order to have a
flourishing Society we need to
we need to suppress some of our base
desires we need to not steal we need to
not murder people we need to not rape
people we need to not cheat people we
need not to fraud people we need to rein
in some of the stuff we want to do in
order to have a good flourishing Society
but anybody if you asked anybody okay
would you rather live in
the United States
well today I don't know people are
probably on the fence about that but
would you even today would you rather
live in the United States where you're
gonna have to play by some rules and
you're gonna have to suppress some of
the things you want to do or would you
rather live in Somalia where there are
no rules and there is no government you
can do whatever you want
until the Pirates show up and kill your
family and take your stuff
nobody would choose Somalia over the
United States because that higher
expression of political freedom
even at the cost of individual freedom
is far far greater right now head on
over to goodranchors.com use code
Knowles a hard year on the economy means
that essential practical gifts are going
to be in high demand this year give the
most essential gift of all America's
best meat and seafood from good Ranchers
with discounts on orders of five boxes
or more you can save on gifts for the
whole family
when you give a box of good ranchers you
are giving them a true Steakhouse
experience with 100 American USDA prime
and upper Choice cuts of beef chicken
seafood other meat delivery companies
and even your local grocery stores
import lower Quality Meat from overseas
do not give your friends and family less
than America's best this year not sure
what to order good ranchers now offers
gift cards so you can let your friends
and family members choose for it
themselves or give the gift of a
subscription
and you can inflation proof someone's
meat budget go to goodranchers.com use
code Knowles kwles at checkout to get 35
off your gift that is goodranchers.com
code Knowles for 35 off good ranchers
American Meat delivered
and so we need to we need to exercise
that exalted Freedom more you're seeing
it happen Maryland even Maryland where
the Republican Governor there's a big
squish named Larry Hogan even he is
flexing that political Freedom right now
and he is Banning state government
devices
uh from having tick tock on them ybs
Tick Tock is owned by the Chinese and it
gives the Chinese Communist party all
sorts of data that we don't want and the
app is just pure poison right I mean the
app is so much more addictive than any
of the social media platforms there was
a study some some time ago that showed
that the average Twitter user is on
Twitter the media and Twitter user is on
Twitter for anywhere from two to four
minutes per day
maybe six minutes you're a heavy user
Tick Tock people are on Tick Tock for 50
minutes plus per day it's not even close
and what are they consuming on Tick Tock
just a bunch of mind-numbing nonsense
so Larry Hogan banded for government
employees on government devices because
of the security concerns
we could go further I'm all for just
Banning Tick Tock just ban it
and especially ban it because they have
been suppressing my account for many
months now so
daily wire runs an account for me for
tick tock I'm not exactly scrolling on
Tick Tock because I'm not a 15 year old
girl but but daily wire runs an account
for me and they've suppressed it like
intensely suppressed when I put out that
video of the Thanksgiving crazy
conservative Uncle a couple days before
Thanksgiving
on Instagram it did about seven million
views on Facebook it did probably
upwards of a million views Twitter
probably upwards of a million views and
then Tick Tock about 7 000 views on my
account
but then other people ripped off the
video and uploaded it they did millions
of views on tick tock
so I it's also
that just Sherman she doesn't like me
very much I guess that Tick Tock is
suppressing me and so I'm all for let's
just ban Tick Tock but even if I didn't
have a personal interest in it it's it's
not good for people does anyone really
think that it's good to be to have 12
year old scrolling Tick Tock all day
long no of course not
in the olden days we would just suppress
that we would use the law to suppress
that sort of a thing but now
the left doesn't want us to because they
want to spread degeneracy and decadence
around the culture and the right doesn't
either because we've bought this this
crazy idea of of some unbridled right to
individual liberty or something like
that which is not Liberty at all it's
really nothing more than license
so good even Utah right now the
Republican Governor there Spencer Cox
has banned Tick Tock from State devices
I say this is not just not an overstep
of the government not just not
a an expression of the tyrannical State
now what I say is it's a good start I
say we need to go much much further the
rest of the show continues now you do
not want to miss it if you're not a
member click the link in the description
and join us
[Music]
[Music]